اخوتي واخواتي الكرام اسعد الله جميع
اوقاتكم معكم عبود ولنبدا حلقتنا من هنا
من ارض الشمال اخوان اليوم ال95 على الحرب
نا خمس ايام بسنا الار بختم الار المهم
اننا يمكن 60 يوم مش شايفين المساعدات
والله الميه اللي بنشربها متنا
احكيلك بلديه مش بلديه بس مجبرين
اشربها وين عيانين منها كل الشعب عيان
صارت المستشفى فيها مرضى اكثر من الدور
هذا اولا هذا من الميه ثانيا من الاكل
برضو يعني انا طلعتلي شجره فول في بطني
متنا متنا من المعلبات ثالثا سطحنا رموا
علينا يعني بدك ايانا نشرب ميه من الارض
طب ما الارض رموا عليها فسفور ابيض راموا
عليها جميع انواع الصواريخ والقدام قتلونا
و شارونا من الميه طب ما احنا متنا من
الميه والله متنا ومع استمرار الحرب متبقي
في شمالنا هنا غزه كما بقت لا شو كما بقت
صحيح مدمره بس يعني حلوه رغم الدمار طول
السما واحلاها والله هذ هذ لازم تكون بحرب
والله تقول في المالديف يا برو ورب الكعبه
بعدين صحيح نسيت اقوللكم لما حكيت الملديف
اذكرت البضاعه عننا غاليه انتم عندكم
غاليه احنا عننا غاليه برو ماكس شو علبه
النوتيلا اللي هقد هذ البسكوته لا شيكل
يعني كم دولار هو دولار مش غالي بس في هذا
الوقت
بنعوزه
l